[Music]
historically there are two approach to
achieve the girl way is to use Raj data
the idea if I can collect all the data
in the world then I believe the
refrigeration then the front this data
is universal because I see all of that
the other approaches are since that goal
of this orientation is to serve
different applications how about I try
the model using application specific
objective functions across many many
different applications you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using
[Music]
dr. John Feng Gao is a veteran computer
scientist and I Triple E fellow and the
current head of the deep learning group
at Microsoft Research he and his team
are exploring novel approaches to
advancing the state-of-the-art on deep
learning in areas like NLP computer
vision multimodal intelligence and
conversational AI today doctor Gao gives
us an overview of the deep learning
landscape and talks about his latest
work on multitask deep neural networks
unified language modeling and vision
language pre-training he also impacts
the science behind task oriented
dialogue systems as well as social chat
BOTS like Microsoft Xiao Weis and gives
us some great book recommendations along
the way that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
jumpin Gao welcome to the podcast
thank you so you're a partner research
manager of the deep learning group at
MSR what's your big goal as a researcher
yourself and what's the big goal of your
group what gets you up in the morning
it's like all the world class research
team so I'll go automatic oh is to
advance the state of the art and we want
to push the AI frontiers by using deep
learning technology or developing new
deep learning technologies that's the
goal I think every good yes but for us
because we are group at Microsoft we
also have a mission to transfer that
latest deep learning and AI technologies
into Microsoft products so that we can
benefit millions of Microsoft users well
interestingly as you talk about the deep
learning group as I understand it that's
a relatively new group here at Microsoft
Research but deep learning is not a new
thing here so tell us how and why this
group actually came about deeply has a
long history but I think the first
deepening model at that time is called
Narada model was developed half century
ago where Edison because the training
ADA available for large scale model
learning is not variable so the
performance of the these newer models
are not as good as the state of the art
model at that time so deep learning only
I think it took off in the last decade
when the large amounts of training ADA
is available in the larger skill
training infrastructure computing
training English stretches available at
Microsoft differently also has a long
history I remember back to 2012 the
speech group at Microsoft Research
already demonstrate the power of deep
learning by applying them to acoustic
modeling they were able to reduce the
error rate of the speech recognition
system by about 10% to 15% that was
considered very
significant milestone that I'm after
almost 10 years
I'll walk without any significant Bouin
there is different in the hit bar so
then in three years the vegan team
computer vision team at Microsoft
develop extremely deep model called the
res net and they reached the human
parity and won a lot of competitions and
I think the first deepening group at
Microsoft Research was founded back to
2014 at the time our focus is to develop
new deep learning technologies for
natural language processing and the web
search and a lot of business
applications in the beginning we think
the deep learning can be not only used
to push the frontier of AI but also to
benefit Microsoft products so there are
two parts in a different group with
research party as incubation hard I was
managing the incubation pod and the dr.
Litton was managing the research part
then after two or three years the
incubation starts to show with promising
business results internally so they move
the team to independent business
incubation division then instant sense
the Big D planning team is into two
parts then later on they move my team to
Dynamics asking me to peel the real
products for customers and at that time
I have to make a choice so I gotta
either stay there to be a general
manager of the new Prada team or move
back to a Mesa as a disabled vet last
year so last year we build a new -
planning group this is probably the
biggest research team and MSA I talk a
little bit more granularly about deep
learning itself and how your particular
career has ebbed and flowed in the deep
learning world I joined Microsoft almost
20 years ago speech group was my first
team I worked on speech then I worked on
natural knowledge processing web search
mushroom translation statistical machine
learning and even you know encouraging
the CSL
Arkadiy I touched the deep running back
to Tucson her when Lita introduced me
the speech the planning model at that
time I remember he was suicide hidden
range my office you know we should build
a deep learning model for natural
language processing
I don't believe that anyway we will try
that the first deep learning model we
developed is called DSM stands for deep
structural similarity model the idea is
very simple we take the web search
scenario as a test case the idea is you
have a query you want to oniony find
relevant documents but unfortunately
documents are written by the author
query issued by the users using very
very different of a carauari in the
language there's a mismatch
so the d-plan your idea is to map post
query and document into a common vector
space we call semantic space in that
space all these concepts are represented
using vectors and the distance between
vectors measures the semantic similarity
the ideas various triple fortunately we
got a lot of pink click data user is
your query and click a document these
are week supervision training later we
have tons of this and then we train the
deep learning model called the SSN it's
fantastic encouraged about this ruler we
decided to form a deep learning team the
key concept of deep learning is
representation learning you know let's
take a natural language example okay
let's say natural sentence consists of
wars and the phrases these are symbolic
tokens the good thing about these
symbolic tokens is a people who
understand them easily but they are
discrete meaning that if you are given
two wars you want asked question how
similar they are deep learning is tried
to map all this Wars into symmetrical
repetitions so that you can measure the
symmetrical similarity and this mapping
is down
a nonlinear function and the deep
learning model in some sense is an
implementation of this nonlinear
function and it says a very effective
implementation in the sense that you can
add more more layers make the very deep
and you have different model
architecture to capture different
aspects of the input and even identify
the features at a different abstract
level then this model needs a large
amounts of data to try I think half
century ago we don't have the computer
power to do this now we have and we also
have a large amount of training for this
that's why I sing a deep learning
takeoff all right well let's talk a
little bit about these representations
and some of the latest research that's
going on today in terms of the kinds of
representations you're dealing with
we've been talking about symbolic
representations both in language and
mathematics and you're moving into a
space where you're dealing more with
neural representations and those two
things that architecture is going to
kind of set the stage for the work that
we're going to talk about in a minute
but I would like you to talk a little
bit about both the definitions of
symbolic representations and neural
representations and why these neural
representations represent an interesting
possibly fruitful line of research let's
talk about two different space wayne is
called a symbolic space years is the
neuro space they have different
characteristics the symbolic space take
natural language as example is what we
are familiar with where the concepts are
represented using words phrases and
sentences these are discrete the problem
of this space is they're natural
languages at highly ambiguous so the
same concept can be represented using
very different words and phrases and the
same words or sentence coming totally
different things given the colonists but
in the sinorix space is hard to tell
yeah
in the neuro space it's different all
the concepts can be represented using
vectors and the distance between vectors
measure the relationship at the semantic
level so we already talked about to
representation money which is the major
task of deeply yeah
deep learning in some senses should map
or the Norwich from the semiotics pace
to neuro space because in the neuro
space all the concepts are represented
using continuous vectors it's a
continuous space it has a lot of very
nice mass properties it's very easy to
train that's why if you have a large
amount of data and you want to try a
highly nonlinear function it's much easy
to do so in the neuro space then in a
single XPath but the disadvantage of the
neuro spaces it's not human
comprehensible because if I give you say
that okay these two concepts are similar
because the vectors of their reputation
are close to each other
how close they are I don't know this is
so hard to explain
it's uninterpretable it's not
interoperable at all that's why people
believe that the neural network model is
like a black box you can give you very
precise prediction but it's hard to
explain how the model come up with the
prediction this applies to some tasks
like image recognition till any model
does great job for tasks like this but
give a different task like mass task if
I gave you a problem statement like
let's say the population of a city is a
five thousand it increased by 10% every
year what's the population after ten
years the different way try to just map
this text into a number without knowing
how the numbers come up with but in this
particular case we need a neuro symbolic
computing ideally you need to identify
how many steps you need to take to
generate the result and for each step
what are the function so this is a much
tougher task are using the current a
deeper anymore look yourself alright so
but that is something you're working on
yes you're trying to figure out how you
can move from symbolic representations
tuner or presentations and also have
them be interpretable yeah exactly like
tasks yeah yeah there's a book called
Thinking Fast and Slow in the book had
to also describe two different systems
that drive the way we sink they call
this system 1 and system 2 system was
like very intuitive fast an emotional
sorry you asked me something I don't
need to think I'll give you answer
immediately because I already answer the
similar questions many many times system
2 is slower more logical but derivative
it's like you need some reason such as
the question I just asked right the mass
program or is the population of the city
you need to sing harder I think the most
of the state of art deep learning models
are life system one it turned out large
amounts of training later each training
example is input outer pairs so the
model learns the mapping between input
output by fitting a nonlinear function
on the data that's it without knowing
how exactly the heck results is
generated but now we are working on in
some sense system to as a neuro symbolic
you not only need to identify to
generate the answer but also needs to
figure out the intermediate steps you
follow to generators
[Music]
your group has several areas of research
interest and I want you to be our tour
guide today and take us on a couple of
excursions to explore these areas and
let's start with an area called neural
language modeling so talk about some
promising projects and lines of inquiry
particularly as they are relate to
neural symbolic reasoning and computing
neural language model is not a new topic
has been there for many years only
recently well no Google proposed a
neural energy model called birth it
achieved state-of-the-art results on
many unhappy tasks because they use a
new neural network architecture color
transformer so the idea of this model is
the representation on e wire vertex they
take they were represented using a
vectors and we are working on the same
problem that we are taking a different
approach so we also want to learn a
representation and try to make the
representation as universal as possible
in the sense that the same
representation can be used to buy many
different applications historical array
there are two approach to achieve the
goal way is to use a large data the idea
if I can collect all the data in the
world then I believe the representation
and the frontage data is universal
because I see all of that the other
approaches are since that goal of this
representation is to serve different
applications how about I try the model
using application specific objective
functions across many many different
network issues so this is called
multitasking on E so Microsoft Research
is taking the multitasking approach so
we have model called MTD hanging unified
language model and that's MTD NN so
multitask deep neural network they for
these two models the multitask learning
is applied at a different stage at the
per training stage and the fan union
stage yeah so this is the neural
language model power and then mainly I
would say this is still like system what
it's thinking thinking fast
okay that's a good anchor well let's
talk about an important line of work
that you're tackling and it falls under
the umbrella of vision in language you
call it VL uh-huh vision language give
us a snapshot of the current VL
landscape in terms of progress in the
field and then tell us what you're doing
to advance the state of the art this is
called the vision language the idea the
same we still learn the replantation
now since we are learning a hidden
semantic space where all the objects
will be represented as a vectors
no matter the original media of the
object it could be a text could be an
image could be a video so remember we
talked about the representation menu for
national Asia right now we extend the
concept extended the modality for a
natural energy to multi modality to
handle natural language vision and the
video the ideas okay give me a video or
image or test I will represent them
using vectors okay by doing so if we do
it correctly then this leads to many
many interesting applications for
example you can do research you just put
a query say I want the image of sleepy
it will return all these images see
that's cross modality because the query
is in natural language and the return
the results in image and you can also to
image caption will give you a clearer
image and the system will generate a
description of the image automatically
this is very useful for essay Breiner
people yeah
well help me think though about other
applications as I said before Brian
people we have a big project called the
seeing AI right that is let's see if
you're bright you're walking on the
street and you're wearing grass the
grass would take pictures of the
surroundings for you and the immediate
area okay there's a car there's a boy
yeah audio audio then tell you what
happens around you and another project
we are working on is called a visual
language and navigation their idea is we
build a 3d environment it's a simulation
but it's a 3d environment and they put a
robot there it's AG yeah and you can ask
the aging to achieve a task by giving
the aging natural energy instructions
okay go upstairs and turn left open the
door go grab a cup of coffee for me
something like that this can be very
very useful for scenarios like mixture
reality right on the holidays I was just
gonna say you must be working with a lot
of the researchers in VR and AR yes
these are sort of potential applications
but we are at the early stage of
developing this Court had knowledge in
the simulated environment so your
upstream in the VL category and as it
trickles down into the various other
applications people can adapt the
technology to what they're what you said
to me let's talk about a third area and
I think this is one of the most
fascinating right now and that's
conversational AI I've had a couple
people on the podcast already who've
talked a little bit about this reham
Monsour and Patrice Samar who's head of
the machine teaching group but I'd like
you to tell us about your work on the
neural approaches to conversational AI
and how they're instantiated in the form
of question answering agents task
oriented dialogue systems are what we
might call bespoke AI and bots chat BOTS
yeah these are all obviously different
types of dialogues and social share was
extremely interesting during the
Microsoft Azure ice I know of it yeah
it's a very popular social chair but it
has attracted more than 600 million
users and what is in China or worldwide
it's the Prada five different countries
so it has Chinese version has Japanese
version English version does have five
different languages yeah it's very
interesting do you have it I have to
which at all right so tell me about it
yeah this is a AI aging but the design
goal of this solution report is
different from sa task oriented ball
that's all it's mainly help you
accomplish a particular task for example
you can use it to poke a movie ticket
reserve a table in the restaurant
get directions yeah get directions and
the social chatter was designed as an AI
companion which can eventually establish
emotional connections with the user so
you can treat it as Fred as your friend
so an AI friend a friend
it's a friend can chat with you about
all sorts of topics it can also help you
accomplish a few tasks if they're simply
enough right now I want to dive a little
deeper on the topic of neuro symbolic AI
and this is proposing an approach to AI
that borrows from mathematical theory on
how the human brain encodes and
processes symbols and we've talked about
it a little bit but what are you hoping
that you'll accomplish with neuro
symbolic AI that we aren't accomplishing
now as I said the key difference between
this approach versus the regulative
planning model is the capability of
reasoning we are different in model it's
like a black box you cannot open so you
take input and gate output this model it
came on the fly I need to find the
necessary components and at
them on the fly that's the key
difference in the older deepening model
it's just one model black box now it's
not a Bravo's it's actually exactly like
what people is sinking mm-hmm
when you face a problem first of all you
divide you conquer right you divided a
complex problem into smaller ones then
for each smaller ones you identify your
search in your memory I need to find a
solution I know you intend all these
solutions together to solve a problem
this problem could be NSYNC before could
be a new problem right that's the power
of the neural symbolic approach so it
sounds like and I think this kind of
goes back to the mission statement of
your group is that you are working with
deep learning toward artificial general
intelligence this is a very significant
step toward that and it's about the
knowledge reusability right by learning
the capability of the composing a
complex problem into simpler ones you'd
know how to solve a new compress problem
and reuse the existing technologies this
is the way we solve that problem well I
think the neuro symbolic approach try to
mimic the way people solve problems
right people as I said it's the system
one system to for this sophisticated
province people's system is it our
system - right you need to analyze the
problem I need to find the key steps and
for each step and any flaw in the
solution all right so our audience is
very technical and I don't know if you
could go in to a bit of a deeper dive on
how you're doing this computationally
mathematically to construct these neuro
symbolic architectures yeah there are
many different ways the learning
challenges that we have a lot of data
but a way to have the labels for the
intermediate steps so the model needs to
learn these intermediate steps all
play in some sense these are hidden
variables there are many different ways
of learning this so there are different
approach one approach is called a
reinforcement learning you try to
assemble in different ways to generals
and if it doesn't give you answer you
twist back and try different
combinations so yeah that's one way of
learning this as well as the model has
the capability of learn all sorts of
combinations in very efficient way we
can solve this problem the idea is a
cinema how peoples of surface K problem
when we are you will learn to solve
these simple problems then we learn the
skill and we combine these basic skills
to solve most sophisticated way we try
to mimic the human learning pattern
using the neural symbolic models so in
that case you don't need to label a lot
of data your label Sam your eventually
the modern lens - since when is or
illness of all these basic tasks and
more importantly the more than Allah how
to consume all these basic skills to
solve a more sophisticated tasks the
idea of pre training models is getting a
lot of attention right now and has been
framed as AI and the big leagues or a
new AI paradigm so talk about the work
going on across the industry in
pre-trained models and what MSR is
bringing to the game the goal of these
Patroni models is to learn a universal
representation of the national language
then there are two strategy of lenin's
the Universal Fantasia well it's to turn
the model large amounts of data if we
get all the data in the world it can be
pretty sure that the model trend is
universal
the other is multitasking Ani and the
Union foreign language model is using
the multitasking in the patrina stage
okay we group the language model into
sweetie
friend categories given the left and
right to predict the world in the middle
as when task
the other task is giving impose sentence
produce the upper sentence second the
third task is giving a sequence you
always want to predict the network based
on the history so these are three very
different tasks cover a lot of natural
language processing scenarios and we use
multi task irani for this unified
language model given a training later we
you know use three different objective
functions to learn jointly the model
parameters the main advantage of the
unified language model is it can be
applied to both natural language
understanding tasks and energy language
generation tasks
[Music]
ai is arguably the most powerful
technology to emerge in the last century
and it's becoming ubiquitous in this
century given the nature of the work you
do and the potential to cause big
disruptions both in technology and in
the culture or society is there anything
that keeps you up at night
and if so how are you working to
anticipate and mitigate the negative
consequences that might result from any
of the work you're putting out you know
there are a lot of open questions
especially in Microsoft we are building
in our products for millions of users by
our users are very different take
Microsoft Azure has the chip our systems
example in order to you know have a very
engaging conversation sometimes a shower
system where vetericyn joke you may find
that you're very interesting funny about
other people may find that you've got
offensive let's have our culture it's
very difficult to find the trade-off you
want the conversation interesting enough
so that you can engage with the people
but you also don't want to offend people
so there are a lot of guidance about who
is in control
rifle if you want to switch a topic to
you allow your aging to switch a topic
as you always follow the topic under the
usability of the user and generally
people agreed for all the human mushroom
systems human needs to be in control all
the time but in reality a lot of
exceptions for what happens if the aging
notice user is going to hurt herself for
employing one situation now we found the
user tortoise for seven hours that's
already 2 a.m. in the morning they also
force user to take a break
we have a lot of sort of rules embedded
into the system to make sure that we
build a system for good people are not
going to misuse the AI technology for
something that it's not gay so are those
like you say you're actually building
those kinds of things in like go to bed
it's past your bedtime mm-hmm something
like that yeah I just remind you Yeah
right so let's drill in a little on this
topic just because I think one of the
things that we think of when we think of
dystopic manifestations of a technology
that could convince us that it's human
where does the psychologically yes in
the entire research communities working
together to set up a some rules to set
up the right expectations for our users
for ample one realizing I believe sure
is that you should never confuse users
she is talking to a port or real human
you should never confuse user forget
about Xiao ice for now and just talk
about the other stuff you're working on
are there any sort of big issues in your
mind that don't have to do with you know
users being too long with the chat BOTS
or whatever but kinds of unintended
consequences that might occur from any
of the other work well foreign put the
respect to the different model right
people any model is very powerful of
prediction scenes people use differently
more the full recommendation all the
time but there's a very serious
limitation of this models is that the
model can correlation but not the
causation for employee if I want to hire
software developer then I've got a lot
of candidates I ask the system to give
me a recommendation the different animal
give me a recommendation so this guy is
gay and I ask the system why because the
candidate is male and
who knew your system is rollin supposed
by actually the system is not wrong the
way we use the system is wrong whether
the system learns the strong correlation
between the gender and the job title but
there's no causality the system does not
have the causality at all
a famous example is you know there's a
strong correlation between the roosters
crow and the sunrise but it does not
cost the sunrise at all but these are
the problem of these different models
people need to aware of the limitation
of the model so that do not misuse them
so one step further
are there ways that you can move towards
causality yes there are a lot of ongoing
works and there's a reason book or the
the book of why the book of why the book
of why by Jodi piers yeah there are a
lot of new models he's developing
wouldn't of the popular model is called
a Bayesian network of course the
Bayesian level can be used in many
applications but he believes this at
least is a promising tool to implement
and the causal models I'm getting a
reading list from this podcast is
awesome well we've talked about your
professional path jumping tell us a
little bit about your personal history
where'd you grow up where did you get
interested in computer science and how
did you end up in AI research I was born
Shanghai I grew up in Shanghai and I
study the design and back to college so
I was not a computer science student at
all I learned to program only because I
wanted a that go at that time its I need
money so you could date a girl so you
get kids that pop
then when but when I was graduating in
year 1999 Microsoft research from the
labs in China I will send them a resume
and got a chance to interview and they
accepted my application that's it
now after that I start to work AI before
that I knew they don't know okay back up
a little
what was your degree in design I got a
new graduate design bachelor degrees
design then I got the electronic or w/e
an electronic engineer and then in
computer science a little later because
I got interested in computer science
after father died ago the computer
science degree yeah a PhD PhD yeah did
you do that in Shanghai or Beijing I'm
sure
so 1999 you need to Microsoft Research
yeah each other okay and then you came
over here then to so far I moved to
remand and to join prodigal pay at that
time my mission at the time was to build
the first nature user interface for
Microsoft Windows Vista and we couldn't
make it after one year I joined the
Microsoft research here I think there
are not more for men to work to do
before we compare the real system for
users let's go upstream a little yeah
and I water for eight years and
Microsoft Research in an epic group and
now your partner research manager for
the deep learning group yeah
what's one interesting thing that people
don't know about you maybe it's a
personal trait or a hobby or a side
quest that may have influenced your
career as a researcher I remember when I
interviewed the microcell research
during the interview I filled almost
other questions yes finally I said okay
it's hopeless I went home the next day I
got a phone call
your height in retrospect I think I did
not give the correct answer I ask the
right questions during an interview I
think is very important for researchers
to learn how to ask the right questions
that's funny how do you get a wrong
answer in an interview because I was
asked the other questions of all the
speech and naturally I had no idea at
all remember that time he asked me to
figure out the algorithm called BtoB and
never heard of that
then I should ask a lot of questions and
he answered a part of it then later he
said I cannot answer more questions
because I answer this question you will
get an answer there shoes I asked the
right questions
let's close with some thoughts on the
potential ahead and here's your chance
to talk to would-be researchers out
there who will take the AI baton and run
with it for the next couple decades what
advice or direction would you give to
your future colleagues or even your
future successors I see a first of all
you needs to be passionate about
research it's critical to I need to find
the problem you're great at want to
devote your lifetime to Walker that's
number one number two after you identify
this problem you want to work on stay
focused
notice we keep your eyes open that's my
advice is that how you did yours I think
so Jonathan Gao thank you for joining us
today
Sasol heavy
[Music]
to learn more about dr. John Fang Gao
and how researchers are going deeper on
deep learning visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]